high inflation is a major talking point
for all turks
the lira has lost nearly half of its
value within the past year as the
central bank made steep cuts to interest
rates
that unorthodox policy caused prices to
soar including for energy and food such
as the ingredients for a turkish
breakfast
to make one kilo of this kosher cheese
you need 11 liters of raw milk the price
of milk doubled with the increase on
electricity natural gas prices are
rising our regular customers cut their
consumption nearly 40 percent turkey's
inflation rate rocketed to 36 percent in
december after a series of interest rate
cuts demanded by president recep tayyip
erdogan it's the highest inflation rate
since his election 20 years ago
we used to buy in kilos last year now in
grams more than half of our retirement
salaries are being spent on gas
electricity phone bills on the first day
high prices are likely to remain a focus
of stock market attention the central
bank is desperately seeking to rebuild
foreign reserves which fell more than 60
percent from mid-december to just 7.5
billion dollars fears of further
inflation rises in the coming months
terrified turks many say the latest
increase to the minimum wage and the
pensions are not enough to make ends
meet
the central bank forecasts an inflation
rate of 23 percent this year some
analysts think that's optimistic and
expect worse to come
we manage somehow we buy the cheapest
things but it's very difficult for
larger families to manage i don't know
how things will work
responding to the economic challenges
government leaders in ankara have
implemented a series of measures during
the past month to persuade savers banks
and companies to hold more lira rather
than foreign currency
those measures studied the lira for now
but many fear their hopes of lower
inflation have already left the station
and they'll soon be paying an even
bigger price for turkey's financial
turmoil cnn solo al jazeera istanbul